I don't know about stocks and shares I
don't know what to put my money in yep I
don't know what trading is why do I
start practical advice don't worry about
it put money into if you're in the UK
into a stocks and shares Isa which is a
savings account or in America your Roth
IRA or 401k and if you can invest money
invest it into a stock market index fund
basically what that means is that
instead of buying one company like apple
or Microsoft or Tesla or Google you're
buying a stake in the top 500 companies
in the in America which would just so
happen like if you put 100 quid in
something called the S P 500 three
pounds would go to Apple and you'd own
three pounds of apple and that means you
can invest in the stock market without
worrying about trying to cherry pick
individual stocks which doesn't work for
anyone unless you're like a very very
professional hedge fund manager and even
then for those guys picking stocks
doesn't really work that would be my
advice to people I think it does help to
have a first principles understanding of
what the stock market isn't and how that
kind of stuff works